welcome to prognosis i'm laura carlson
today we're bringing you a special
episode of the podcast it's a close look
at how the novel coronavirus lived
before it entered humans and who it
lived in bats they are almost certainly
the source of this pandemic but they may
also hold the clues to stopping the next
one scientists have learned that the new
corona virus shares 96% of its genetic
makeup with a virus previously detected
in a kind of bat known as the horseshoe
bat from the Yunnan Province in China it
turns out these bats are very logical
treasure troves so many of the
infectious agents we worry most about
coexist in virtual harmony with these
nocturnal creatures Bloomberg senior
editor Jason Gale takes us back to the
mid-1990s where a surprise finding by
scientists in Australia led to the
emergence of the backpack a group of
researchers who not only discovered a
whole genus of dangerous viruses but
found what could be the precursor of the
novel coronavirus
they're also laying the groundwork for
potential treatments here's Jason bats
and viruses can be traced to an
Australian veterinarian dr. Hume Field
the son of a policeman who grew up in
various parts of the northeastern state
of Queensland where he developed a
fascination for Australia's native fauna
I always had an interest in animals and
I guess growing up as a kid I can
remember my parents saying our human
loves animals he's going to be a vet and
this was really a bit of a throwaway
line because nobody in our family had
ever been to university let alone to a
five year veterinary course but
but nonetheless the sidam acetyl coline
yes at least with me when I caught up
with him he was in his home office in a
leafy coastal area southeast of Brisbane
you could hear chattering wildlife and
vocal pets as well as drought breaking
rain Jim graduated from the University
of Queensland in 1976 he worked for a
couple of years in a small animal
practice but his interest in wildlife
led him to pursue further study in the
evenings first in environmental science
then a doctorate in the mid 1990s it
allowed him to combine his love of
native animals with emerging diseases at
a time when the state's agricultural
authorities were trying to figure out
the source of a deadly horse disease it
was a virus that infected twenty
racehorses stapled in the Brisbane
suburb of Hendra in 1994 it's thought to
have started when a man called drama
series was brought to the stables after
she'd been grazing in a field at Cannon
Hill on the other side of the Brisbane
River drama series died two days later
and subsequently all of the other horses
fell ill 13 of them died what was
especially alarming about this disease
was that across the species barrier a
trainer and another person tending to
the horses became ill with a flu-like
illness within days of drama series
death the stablehand recovered but the
trainer died of respiratory and kidney
failure the virus was eventually
isolated and named Hendra virus after
the suburb where it was found
Hume was asked to help determine how a
drama series might have caught the virus
he went searching the paddock where
she'd been grazing and presumably had
become infected
he caught rodents possums feral cats and
reptiles and tested them for Hendra
virus when the results came back
negative
he went searching for clues by the
people rescuing vulnerable wildlife here
in Australia they're sometimes referred
to as wildlife carers so we subsequently
broadened our search and started using
wildlife carers as I as a con you did
you like to be able to collect samples
from sick and injured animals that were
in their care
and it was in that process so again
quite serendipitous that we actually
sampled we were sampling kangaroos were
sampling possums with a sampling the
usual things Doc's a whole range of
things that would come into the wildlife
carers and there were flying foxes only
sampled some flying foxes this was over
a period of months and lo and behold we
found antibodies to handler virus in
some flying foxes so we did some more
flying foxes and then we looked at some
flying foxes you know can in captive
population at zoos etc and and that's
how we identified flying foxes as being
at that stage a possible reservoir then
we went on to do further studies
eventually detected an isolated virus
etc etc and so now flying foxes on at
least a couple of species of flying
foxes in Australia I recognise this the
primary reservoir hosts of Hendra virus
flying foxes aren't actually foxes
they're a large fruit eating bat with a
kind of fox-like face and expression
they weigh up to a couple of pounds and
their wings can span more than three
feet the finding of Hendra virus in bats
was important not just because it helped
identify the pathway by which horses and
people were being infected it also made
scientists alert to other viruses bats
could potentially carry about a year
after Hugh made the discovery of
hantavirus and flying foxes another
opportunity to explore the ecology of
viruses and bats presented itself this
time in Malaysia where pigs and pig
farmers were getting sick by mid 1999
more than 265 people had fallen ill with
encephalitis or inflammation of the
brain of those cases 40 percent were
fatal there are also 11 cases of either
encephalitis or respiratory illness
including one death in neighboring
Singapore scientists found the viral
sauce it was named Nipah virus which it
turned out was from the same family as
Hendra virus hume was asked to help
investigate the source
what if someone who was they might be
able to guide and work with them to find
out the natural reservoir maker so no
not we knew about hindering bats then we
immediately focus not exclusively but we
certainly focused on flying foxes in
Malaysia and it wasn't too long before
we found the evidence just as Hendra
virus did the discovery of NEPA
underscored the risks that emerge at the
interface of wildlife farm animals and
humans professor Trevor drew is the
director of the Australian animal health
laboratory at jalan just outside of
Melbourne it's carried out key research
on both Hendra and Nipah viruses
according to Trevor the emergence of
Hendra and then NEPA identified the ways
in which bat borne viruses can spill
over and infect other species and nipa
virus was a disease also of fruit bats
in malaysia initially and that virus got
into pigs because the there were they
were starting to put pig farms into more
forested areas and the feces from the
bats got into the pigs dies and and was
thought to have infected the pigs that
way and it killed hundreds of pigs if
not thousands of pigs NEPA isn't just
confined to Malaysia
over the past decade it's caused
outbreaks in India and Bangladesh that
have killed dozens of people
we also now also also know from
incidents in Bangladesh of outbreaks of
Nipah virus that you don't need the pig
that the that the bat can actually also
infect humans directly via drinking out
of vessels of palm sap that are put onto
the tree to to harvest the palm sap and
people drink this palm sap but so does
the bat and they will come down and the
saliva from the bat can contaminate them
the palms happened in fact the human
directly so we know that that that is
one incident but certainly in Malaysia
now they're very very careful not to
have pig farms near
but roosts an even more dramatic
outbreak occurred just a few years later
severe acute respiratory syndrome or
SARS emerged in southern China in 2002
it's a deadly a cousin of covert 19 that
quickly spread across the world Jim
field was asked to help investigate its
source growing awareness there seemed to
be something special about bats and
these viruses then we hypothesize that
bats may play a role in the origins of
SARS and so we went down that track it's
interesting to reflect on the
significance of the discovery of species
of bats and flying foxes and as the
natural reservoir of Hendra virus
because really that finding I think has
potentially colored the identification
of bats or you know sort of underlying
the identification of various species of
bats being associated with with this
suite of other emerging diseases that
would see the group that Hume just
referred to also includes a bola viruses
and lyssavirus
which causes rabies as well as a number
of corona viruses including SARS and
most likely the one responsible for the
covert 19 pandemic so what is it about
bats that makes them such great virus
vectors that's odd unique if you think
about it in terms of them being a mammal
that can fly so so that's mammals like
produced milk they suckle a young they
got this amazing evolutionary adaptation
or ability to be able to fly so they're
highly mobile they also typically live
in large populations colonies roost
whether it's the big fruit bats or
flying foxes with
small micro bats in caves and and
typically these groups have mixed
species as well they're relatively
long-lived
animals as a taxon you know flying fox
have certainly recorded by thinking
captivity to live well into 2007
wouldn't live that long in nature but
sooner they live for years so all of
these factors are very attractive for
mammalian virus survival and
dissemination if you like
according to Hume bats have evolved and
adapted to coexist with the viruses that
infect them and so the thinking was that
well you know these are just viruses of
bats and the bats are used to them
because they've evolved with from and
that's why the bats don't get sick with
these viruses but if they spill into
other no even logically naive species
then they have a dramatic typically
dramatic and often fatal infection but
more recently people have dug a bit
further to try to understand if there is
indeed something else going on with bats
in it seems human now works as a science
and policy advisor with the eco health
alliance it's a new york-based
NGO that works to protect wildlife and
public health from the emergence of
disease spillover events are becoming
more risky bats as we heard are coming
into closer contact with farm animals
but they're also coming into closer
contact with humans a key reason for
that is that bats are losing their
habitat critically they're losing their
natural food source
what you're hearing is the sound of
gray-headed flying foxes roosting it's
dusk and I'm sitting on a grassy Bank of
the Torrens River in the centre of
Adelaide the capital of South Australia
I'm literally a stone story from the
University of Adelaide my alma mater
behind me and the Adelaide Zoo on the
other side of the river this is a
popular place for the 20,000 bats
hanging upside down from the eucalyptus
trees above me it's a familiar place for
dr. Marc ship Australia's chief
veterinarian who is based in Canberra
but also grew up in South Australia Marc
is the president of the World
Organization for Animal Health he told
me that bats have taken up residency in
Adelaide and other urban centres but not
by choice so almost every city in
Australia now has a resident roost of
flying foxes and the fruiting and the
flowering trees that these bats normally
feed on have been largely removed from
rural Australia and so they've been
forced in into urban centres and
suburban parkland where there is some
flowering trees and some fruiting trees
but these are not the preferred diet of
the flying foxes and they're putting
those flying foxes under stress we've
seen a number of incidents in Australia
over recent years with large-scale
mortalities of flying foxes due to heat
events here in Canberra we had a large
hail storm event which killed over 300
flying foxes it reflects that they're in
centres where they would normally not be
present and that they're under stress
when they're in those centres there's
another concern with bats roosting in
places like this where horses are being
kept less than a mile from here for us
that the concern is that where we have
parkland we often have horses and we
know that flying foxes can transmit
Hendra virus to horses and that those
horses in turn can transmit that
virus to humans and that's a fatal
disease of both horses and of humans and
then and then that there is the risk
that the bats themselves will transmit
directly to human populations and there
are a number of corona viruses and other
viruses that bats carry and can transmit
to the human population but there are
other consequences of the loss of that
habitat while these animals can carry
some pretty nasty viruses they perform
functions vital for the Australian
ecosystem they play very important roles
in terms of insect control of
pollination and of seed dispersal the
the role that they play in keeping down
insect numbers which and and insects can
transmit disease particularly in
northern Australia is very important and
then that the role that they play in
pollinating plants as they move between
plants and then dispersing seeds when
they eat fruits and and disperse the
seeds so that those plants become
established in other areas is very
important and is a role that no other
participant in the ecosystem can play
in the mammalian world lifespan is
generally proportional to body size and
metabolic rate that's defy both these
rules one bat species weighing just
seven grams or a quarter of an ounce can
live for more than 40 years it's one of
a number of quirks of these critters
professor Linda Wang has been unlocking
the secrets of bats since the 1990s he
was the scientist who isolated and
characterized Hendra virus and
identified its viral aaja cool cousin
NEPA actually it was linfer who named
the genus to which they both belong
henna by virus back then he was working
at the Australian Animal Health
Laboratory just outside of Melbourne he
now heads the emerging infectious
diseases program at Singapore's Duke and
u.s. medical school for the past 13
years he's devoted his career to
studying bat biology and bat immunology
particularly its defense against viruses
he's brought a number of researchers
along with him in Australia Singapore
and now China where he was born and did
his undergrad degree in scientific
circles Lin furs sometimes known as the
Batman people give me the nickname of
Batman that I try to cut them so that I
actually don't start about that Batman
lymphocercoma zation 'he's Emergency
Committee advising the Director General
on the current covert 19 pandemic it's a
reflection of the knowledge he in his 20
person lab have amassed on these animals
and we have been focusing on the
question of why that why bats are so
different why they can carry so many
laws and themselves to not get sick and
why bats live so long considered their
living environment and also the strap
they have during fly and also the
patterning they're exposed is the much
much more than a non-prime level it
turns out that the immune system of
these flying mammals is different to
that of terrestrial mammals bats reactor
infections at an earlier stage arresting
them before they cause any disease that
enables bats to avoid the damaging
inflammatory immune response other
mammals including humans often mount in
response to viral
infections so our current working
hypothesis is easier bats have a much
better defense was rhetoric but all
we're just studying covert 19 and other
pathogenic viruses have observed that
when the body initially recognizes an
infection various white blood cells that
consume pathogens and help heal damaged
tissue act as first responders in some
severe infections the body's effort to
heal itself may be too robust leading to
the destruction of not just virus
infected cells but healthy tissue
it's that inflammatory response that
ends up being deadly bats don't suffer
the same fate that can defend themselves
launch this inflammation but they don't
go overboard okay so this is a very big
area of research and I think we humans
can learn lympha says he's convinced
bats offer important insights into the
regulation of the immune system that may
inform ways the human body can better
tackle cope at 19 and other viral
diseases so my closing now is the study
is basically learning from bat that has
so much the teachers for one thing
linfer is intrigued that a species about
that weighs just seven grams has a heart
that beats more than 1,000 times per
minute during flight it flies for five
to eight hours daily and can live for 43
years this is all done with the same
heart was that any medication with her
in the hygiene you know imagine that
right it's incredible it's little wonder
that Linfen is working with
cardiologists who study the heart
muscles of bats just one of a number of
medical disciplines he's recruited into
his backpack I have been able to
mobilize not only infection disease
people genomics people immunologist and
the cancer biologists and now
cardiologists our collaboration leaders
started back my personal dream you have
enough money is to attach a bat
Institute I think that we have lots to
learn from bat bats can help us identify
what viruses or pandemic potential
working in nature as well as ways we
might be able to mitigate their threat
they're just one example of how humans
are profoundly affected by what happens
in global ecosystems to anticipate
prevent and respond to disease threats
like over nineteen means taking an
increasingly wide-angled look at the
natural world and that's it for this
special episode of the prognosis daily
edition for more on the pandemic from
our bureaus around the world visit
bloomberg.com slash coronavirus and if
you like the podcast please take a
moment to rate us and leave us a review
on Apple podcasts or Spotify it helps
more listeners find our global reporting
the prognosis daily Edition is hosted by
me Laura Carlson the show is produced by
me Topher four has Jordan gasped or a
and Magnus Henriksen reporting by Jason
Gail original music by Leo sidrón our
editors are francesca levy and Rick shy
francesca levy is Bloomberg's head of
podcasts thanks for listening
[Music]